I knew I would want to get married again
I kind of put that out in the universe
and it came true I'm just as shocked as
you are ha ha ha shocked and thrilled
alrighty well we have to start with the
big news congratulations thank you Tom
and I have been together a short time
and I knew after the first couple of
weeks that he was gonna be my next
husband but I said to production you
know this would be my next husband like
come on really LuAnn what they didn't
know is that I got married the first
time after two weeks being a countess is
not a job it's it's actually an honor
now i remember reading a while ago that
if you ever get remarried you lose the
countess title officially right well you
know that's true and and I'll be mrs. D
mrs. dagostino instead of mrs. Ellis eps
and that's okay you know people are like
we want to call you the countess we
don't want to call you the man I'm like
you can always call me the countess is
their kind of a vibe or a theme for the
big day you know what it's threefold so
it's Tom's birthday is gonna be 50 it's
our wedding and it's New Years Eve so I
felt I feel like I should change it up
so I'm gonna do three different dresses
why not my big night why not have a
little dresses you can't keep avoiding
me Carol actually I did walk away are
your co-stars gonna be out the big day
Bethany told us she probably won't be
yeah well you know what that remains to
be seen let's see how the ladies behave
at the Reunion ah and then I will make
my decision
you